when you watch your body transform you
get the loudest signal from your
subconscious that you can
change you have to really go back to
first principles and think
things out for yourself whether they're
scientific principles or moral
principles or
business ideas or product ideas i've
always told people that
if you can wake up in the morning with a
smile on your face excited about your
day
knowing it's going to be a good day
you're successful
want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you've got
something more inside you you've got
michael jordan level genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the seven
rich people habits that you need to try
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one learn and improve with charles koch
everybody who's watching this will want
to know how do you take a 12 million
revenue company to roughly 120 billion
revenue company without going public
what is the key
secret to doing that well the secret was
that
that i was as i said i didn't feel
i was fully using my capabilities so i
read everything i could
from all different all relevant
disciplines all different perspectives
to find principles that i could use
and apply in the business in my life to
enable me to believe in myself and i
started applying them in business
and they worked they worked beyond my
belief
and beyond anything i hoped for and that
absolutely transformed my life and so my
whole life has been
looking for principles that'll enable me
to contribute
uh or improve the the principles we're
implying
and better apply them and
and so every day is like i'm reborn
habit number two
show up with grant cardone showing up
means
showing up it don't mean you got to the
office
you understand doesn't mean you came to
work
for me showing up means i show up i've
been showing up since i was
25 years old man before that i wasn't
showing up
i was showing off i was acting a fool
being a fool high school i didn't show
up i went to class i never showed up
my body went in the room see showing up
doesn't mean you got there showing up
means you got there
and then you showed up again and then
you showed up again and you showed up
again
means you show up for the class you show
up for the homework you show up for the
class you show up for the homework you
show up for the test
you freaking get a perfect grade means
you keep showing up to the next level
and i hear a lot of people talking about
showing up you know showing up's not
everything let me tell you something
showing up when you show up the right
way
johnny you got to put your seatbelt on
when you show up the right way when you
show up the right way
showing up is 100 of success
that means you show up and then you show
up again you show up again you keep
getting better at your game
you can't keep showing up as the old you
you got to show up as the new you you
know mercedes-benz
if they just kept building this vehicle
the way they used to build it
and didn't keep showing up with new
technology
new suspension new seats
new choices new colors
you know the matte black the red guts
new navigation system got to have a new
game every day baby
you got to have a new game every day and
the follow up you got to have
you got to have new follow-up you can't
have a new i can't can't do the same
thing you did that didn't work yesterday
we're doing a 10x growth conference i'm
doing a 10x this year
i'm not doing the same 10x i did last
year it's a new year new time
new audience new speakers
now that being said when i show up for
the 10x growth conference in las vegas
on 2
20 20 20. i just spent
six hours this morning working out what
we're doing
okay i'm not going to show up the way i
did last year jumping out of a damn
plane
let me show up in a different way okay
in a different way in a unique way
but i am not going to abandon the things
that work for the audience and for
myself
so you got to find this really really
cool mixture between
repeating what works and showing up as a
new person all the time
if you're reading a book okay you
listening to music
going to an event uh
speaking at an event let's say you're
speaking in an event it's
it's the 700th time you did that
presentation you got to show up new
again
johnny comes to work with his camera and
we're doing a show today
johnny needs to show up new looking for
new angles new colors new
you got to show up every day new folks
you're new man you're new
ladies and gentlemen you're new every
day you're new or
guess what you're old nobody wants old
i don't want to get old i don't want
stale
i don't want yesterday's i don't want
leftovers
i don't i don't i know i know when
somebody's repeating something wrote
they're just giving me the same i don't
mind some [ __ ]
but it's got to be fresh i need some
fresh bowls
so i don't mind i don't mind a little
bit of [ __ ] i just don't want the
same thing
okay that guy's told that story a
thousand times and it looks like the
thousand
thousand times not in a good way either
so you gotta keep showing up showing up
means you're looking for deeper levels
to show up to pay attention
that's what i do every day every day i
come to work i'm like show up man show
up for every little problem
show up for every little opportunity
show up for every little little
nuance little angle little particle
little movement that's why i see all
this stuff
why is that not cleaned up why is this
not cleaned up what's it why don't
somebody pick that up
who's that new person here hey you
feeling
all right today how many times have i
asked you that before you all right
today i know it's little things
it's simple it costs nothing to do this
show up it costs you nothing
and it makes all the difference man
showing up you'll see
things that no one else sees and and
you know the good news is anybody can do
this you just got to make a commitment
to show up
hey man how you doing buddy good how are
you you got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here habit
number three love what you do with mark
cuban
everybody just defines success
differently you know i've always told
people that
if you can wake up in the morning with a
smile on your face excited about your
day
knowing it's going to be a good day
you're successful
and so in terms of your business you
know you got to live at
some level right but if you love what
you're doing and you
love it's not work right i mean we're
not again
all these stories that there's too many
stories just television shut up
um early on i had to teach myself how to
program
and you know whether it's basic c plus
plus
database applications and i would start
you know writing these applications for
customers
and i start working on it working on it
working on it and i look up and i've
been sitting there for 24
26 hours not realizing you know that i i
hadn't moved
this whole time i loved what i was doing
now i was sleeping six guys living six
guys in a three-bedroom apartment
i was starving right you know i had a
hole in the floorboard of my car
but i knew that you know there was a
light at the end of the tunnel if i kept
on getting better at what i did
but had i not had the financial success
i still would have loved it
habit number four stop conforming with
larry ellison
think things out for yourself come to
your own judgments don't simply
conform uh to conventional ways of
thinking conventional ways of dressing
conventional ways of acting that a lot
of this
a lot of things are are based on fashion
even morality at times is based on
fashion
it was once found you know slavery was
once not considered not to be immoral
uh you know people are you know people
are shocked that
the uh the ancient greeks had slaves
that
that we had slavery in this country as
recently as you know 130 140 years ago
so there are more moral thoughts you
have to really go back to first
principles and think
things out for yourself whether they're
scientific principles or moral
principles or
business ideas or product ideas you have
to think things out for yourself
habit number five exercise with tom
bilyeu
they're very concrete habits that you
can use
that i have used once you get your mind
in the right place once you believe that
it can happen
this is what i did i worked out why
because it helped me gain control of my
mind
one it was micro credibility with myself
every day i said i was gonna do
something i did it
two when you're suffering and you're
willing to fight through it you tell
yourself a story
that you're willing to pay the price to
become what you want to become and also
and this may be the most important
reason each and every one of you should
start working out
and it has nothing to do with living
longer because we could get hit by a
meteorite who knows
so i'm not even worried about that but i
am worried about this
when you watch your body transform you
get the loudest signal from your
subconscious that you can
change that you can change anything you
want that you can change your bicep your
tricep your quad whatever it is you want
something that you literally could not
do the day before you can do today
and your mind sees that that's true
your mind sees that something you
couldn't pick up yesterday you can pick
up today
and it begins to ask itself well if
that's possible then what else is
possible
now for me finding my center was also a
very important thing so i work out first
the next thing i do without fail is
meditate
i do a just breathe meditation where i'm
simply trying to calm my mind
then i do what i call thinkitating
during meditating
i get into an alpha wave state brain
pattern which enhances creativity and
unique connections
i'm not worried about whether i'll ever
think a unique thought i am simply
interested in the unique connections
that i will make
that no one else before me or after me
will ever make because their
circumstances are different than mine
and that to me is what makes each of us
a beautiful snowflake
is we're all going to make connections
that other people might not make
and so during thinking i take advantage
of a problem i'm trying to solve
i smash it together with my alpha wave
state and i see what comes out of it
i read i read obsessively because i
believe in one simple math equation
ideas in
equal ideas out and then i keep a list
of the most important things i'm trying
to accomplish
if you're trying to become something you
need to know what that something is
habit number six change your spending
habits with kevin o'leary
there's a big difference between saving
and investing
saving you don't even beat the inflation
rate anymore basically
that's the amount of cash you should
have on hand just in case poopoo hits
the fan
catastrophic illness in your family car
accidents something tragic occurs
i like to have 90 days of
window so whatever it costs you to live
for a month
have three of those just in case poopoo
hits the fan so 90 days
but then you should find a way to change
your
expending habits and you know the people
spend money on all kinds of crap they
don't need
you look at your closet full of clothes
you never wear anymore shoes you don't
wear it anymore
and all the junk you don't need in
consumer electronics take a little bit
of that and just
invest it not save it invest it and that
is where you take and use an app like
beanstalks
to pull 100 bucks out of your account
and automatically put it into a wide
diverse portfolio
that you hope will achieve six to eight
percent a year over a long period of
time
that's how you become a millionaire when
you're in your 60s and you have a nest
egg
that you can fall against when you want
to retire as opposed to having nothing
in them
and habit number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is move focus from the balance sheet
with michael milken
i think empathy seeing the world through
others and the ability to communicate it
you know it's
the world it's not size anymore
size does not protect you and so it's
new ideas and
i think many people in finance were so
focused on the balance sheet
or income or results from the past
rather than what the future was like
great leaders can take a difficult
situation turn around and make it good
poor leaders can take a good situation
and have it deteriorate
there is this leadership of change
and so to me i always focused on what
was not on the balance sheet and that is
the talent of the management
and the talent of leadership you know a
leader has to convince
people to follow them and have that
passion and vision and you can see it
in their eyes i'm sure you see it in the
short
presentations on shark train but there
is a difference
between and once capital
was no longer constrained which occurred
during the 1970s and 80s
if you look at the united states small
and medium companies created
62 million jobs in the last third of the
20th century
and large companies created minus four
so now
the large company didn't have the
protection that they were the only one
who had access to capital so
to me who is the leadership what is
their vision what is their commitment
and you have one to your left here
that we would all follow around the
world now i've got a special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and what is your plan of action for the
next week the sign says that when you
just watch a video you get motivated you
get inspired
you have a 35 chance of actually doing
something following through
that believe nation is not enough 35
percent
is not enough we got to do something but
when you get inspired by watching a
video like this
and then you create a plan of action
your chances of following
will jump to 91 and when you commit
publicly
like putting your comment down below
with your plan it jumps to 95
that's what i want for you i want you to
take action your dreams are too
important
your life matters your mission has to
happen
so question of the day your biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week put it down in the comments below
and i'm going to celebrate alongside
with you to be serious if you want to be
the
next dangote is that you have to have a
very big heart
you have to take quite a lot of risk
calculated risk first of all you have to
make sure that
you're honest you must make sure that
you don't destroy the
name you know because your name is very
important that the
most valuable asset that you have going
forward
if you don't have a good name even the
banks doesn't matter how big you are
they're not going to touch
whenever i get an idea i have to do
something immediately
trust your ideas believe that they're
amazing and and manifest them into the
world i love it i'm not
taking it from the approach of i want
this book to be a new york times
bestseller and i'm sitting there
visualizing my book being a new york
times bestseller i'm not visualizing
myself
being on brendon burchard's stage in
puerto rico to a couple thousand people
uh that's not the process that i
typically go through although i'm open
to that maybe being a mistake i don't
know
it's never really felt like it's worth
it
i don't know i'm sitting there i've done
it many times sitting there visualizing
i've never
really felt like that made a difference
i'm open to being
totally wrong but how i do apply it and
massively seen an impact is as soon as i
get an idea for something
it's it's go time trust that vision that
came to you
trust that idea it's in your head and do
something immediately about it
when i thought about the idea of having
a house
of building a custom home i then went
off and built the 5 000 square foot
custom home
like inside of the year we had the whole
thing done when i thought about
silly things like i thought about having
a mannequin i was watching
green arrow on tv and i loved how they
all had their their mannequins when they
were in their
their lair or their realm they had their
outfits their costumes on
a mannequin and i thought i feel like
i'm i'm the green arrow i'm
i got the deep hood look i could be this
is this is the believe arrow right
uh i want a mannequin too and then
inside of a week
i had my own mannequin here and so it
may seem crazy mainly wild but that's
how i
tend to operate and i think it's amazing
right now i'm thinking about doing a 30
day challenge on my youtube channel my
main youtube channel where every day for
the next 30 days
i have a series of videos to help you
build a better life so like 30 days to a
better life
and it's going to be some of our best
work
and i thought of the idea and now
immediately we're doing it
and so trusting the ideas that come to
me
and then immediately creating them and i
guess manifesting them into the world
i am a thousand percent all in on
the sitting and visualizing
the thing that i want i have a struggle
with and i'm open to
um making it better and and being
changed
where i face the hardest time with this
is my health so
i broke my neck last year right i wore
this for for
uh 60 days taking it off for 10 minutes
a day that was it
and i had a concussion and i had two
spots in my neck that were broken
and i did some meditation with a guy
named michael edwards who
led me through this guided meditation
and he helped me and he was doing it
with me
in person over over the phone sending me
videos
and first off was getting the concussion
away because i'd never had a concussion
before and the meditation i found really
helped the concussion
the second part was the visualization so
i have a bone in the back of my neck
that broke off
so the big bone broke and it's healed
the little bone just kind of broke up
like the tip
like imagine i guess a fingernail kind
of hanging loose right
and it broke off and the doctor said
it's not going to come back together
and and it's not worth going and doing
surgery on it because
it's not a big deal don't worry about it
and
michael was convinced that i could heal
myself
and i could make that bone come back
together and so
every uh night and every morning i would
do it twice a day
meditating and visualizing the neck
coming back together and
and you know take some you know hand
sanitizer or
not hand sensitive take some lotion and
and you know put it on my neck and just
as i'm
to get more tactical like as i'm doing
it the the bones connecting
i talked to john assaraf who is a
another you know legendary expert in his
field and he's peacefully convinced that
it can come back together through
visualization through meditation
i haven't done it yet i haven't i
haven't i haven't cracked the code on
how to do it i wish i did
we did x-rays uh 60 days later and
it's still just as disconnected it's
still just it didn't move
a centimeter a millimeter closer and
that was honestly a little bit uh you
know
negative or low or defeating and and my
motivation to do it as intensely has
has waned i haven't been doing it twice
a day every day
i still want to believe that as possible
and i still kind of believe that it's
possible and maybe that's not enough
maybe that's the problem
uh maybe the problem was i never
believed enough that it could happen and
that's why it didn't happen
so i would i would love for that to work
i would love for
meditation to work i've meditated with
i don't know how many different people
so many different people i've never
really felt the benefit
[Music]
of having a meditation just feels like
i'm like i'm sitting down nothing wrong
with it just i don't feel
extra clarity or anything coming out of
the meditation so
i believe that it has worked for other
people i believe that it can work for me
i haven't found the path to make it work
so that's where i'm still struggling and
trying to improve and trying to get
better and reaching out to experts and
why i still
feature people on my channel because i'm
trying to learn through the process as
well
but but the idea of taking the ideas
that do come to you and taking immediate
action on them
right the last letters of of law of
attraction is action doing something
trusting them i think a thousand percent
that can serve you it has served me i
know for sure can serve you
to learn to trust your ideas and do
something immediately
today about it and then build momentum
towards it and that big crazy thing that
you have in your mind may not even be
that big and crazy
once you actually start taking some
action on it and so that part i'm a
thousand percent down on and you need to
do something today in your life to
change
and the other side i'm totally open to
feedback suggestions on how
i can get better how you can get better
my son
in 2014 gave me a book by joseph
campbell called hero of thousand faces
and basically he described that these
things happen
you know everybody crashes and then
you're faced with that crash
and you either have an epiphany or you
don't
now you either walk off the field and
say hey i don't want to do this anymore
and you give up on that
going after your audacious goals or you
gain really
humility you you know how do you feel
that you're going to be wrong and so
i think then that whole notion is
um you know to come back with the
finding the smartest people i could find
who disagree with me
um also i'm in the investment management
business that you have to bet against
the consensus
otherwise you can't make money because
it's in the price and you have to bet
against the consensus and be right or as
an entrepreneur
i'm an entrepreneur i had to bet against
the consensus
and be right and so to gain that
humility
was the the thing so you either get off
the field or you learn
there is a reason many of the great
women and men of the world the great
history makers the great poets the great
philosophers the great
movement makers rose before the sun
there is
a magic in the air at 5 00 am and that's
why the 5am club is so transformational
because
it's the time of greatest quietude and i
believe
tranquility is the new luxury on our
planet it is
a time of intimate creativity because
you've just been rested your brain is
fresh there's
there's latest there's there's very
recent cutting edge science coming out
now when you sleep your brain
actually has a mechanism to wash itself
when you wake up in the morning your
willpower
is strongest when you wake up in the
morning you've got a full well of mental
focus and we know that focus in our
world is even more valuable than
intelligence and i could go on and on on
the benefits i mean
you get up at 5 00 a.m you've got the
world to yourself there's no
crowds you can think you can plan you
can
care for yourself in a world where so
many people are so depleted
and so the five it the 5am club really
is a game changer and then
it's not just get up at 5am and you know
scratch your stomach or
stir up at the ceiling or look at your
phone or look at especially
i believe you can play with your phone
or change the world you don't get to do
both yeah
and so uh it the 5am club method is
based on the 20 20 20 formula i'm happy
to get into it but that is
tell us what it is that's the
revolutionizer and and it started from
my experience with working with many
billionaires i've i've coached many of
the most successful financiers and
titans of industry for for over two
decades
and one of the things i would run them
through is the way you begin your day
sets up the way you live your day
and so the 20 20 20 formula that the
book is based upon is
pretty simple i i go into great detail
in the book but
essentially it's from five to five
twenty the first pocket is
move and i'm a fanatic about
neuroscience and
why do you get up and move because
you're going to release serotonin which
is going to make you feel better you're
going to release dopamine which is the
pleasure and inspirational
neurotransmitter
you're going to release norepinephrine
which will boost your focus
you'll promote neurogenesis marie you
can actually grow new brain
cells you'll increase your metabolic
rate so
the way you begi the way you feel when
you first wake up is not the way you're
going to feel at 5
20. second pocket of the 20 20 20
formula 20 minutes from 5 20 to 5 40
that's on reflection so a lot of us are
busy but what's the point of being
busy if you're doing the wrong things
the the billionaires the great creatives
the people of great impact the people
who live beautiful lives are very
intentional
they're very deliberate they're very
conscious so for 20 minutes
you write in a journal you can visualize
you can pray
you can meditate you can simply
contemplate how you're going to live
your day what you want to stand
for during the day for example and then
the final pocket of the 20 20 20 formula
is all about
grow and that's where you you you just
read from a biography or a business book
or a philosophy book or a
watching marietv well especially
watching tv yeah
of course that's the game changer isn't
it and so that's 20 minutes of growing
most of your viewers out there sitting
inside their head other words from their
mother and father
go to school get a job
pay taxes save money
buy a house because it's an asset get
out of debt
yeah and invest in the stock market that
creates poor people
it's a hypnosis train going through your
brain
so when people say how do i change my
life when you change those words
i wouldn't go to school because you
learn nothing about money in school
ask i wouldn't get a job because if i
have a job i'm an employee
and then i'd pay taxes and i don't pay
taxes
and i don't save money and i use debt to
get rich
and i don't invest in the stock market
that's why i'm rich
and so the young people who are
listening right now are saying but
that's what my mom and dad said
but that's what mom and dad say all over
the world
so to the young people i just say
challenge or question
what you've been taught because from the
bible
i'm not religious yeah the word becomes
flesh
so if you say go to school he said but
i learned nothing about money get a job
you become an employee
yeah if you're an employee you work for
money i pay taxes
then they tell you to save money why
would you save money when the
government's printing money
you know and get out of debt well
debt is money i use debt to get rich
most people use debt to get poor
and invest in the stock market i don't
invest in the stock market
so when you when you wonder why so many
people struggle
financially because they haven't
challenged the hypnosis
the words go to school
get a job work hard
save money get paid taxes
until you question those hypnotic
trances
you don't change in terms of clarity
what is that habit that you take on on a
daily or
monthly basis with habit with clarity
what do you think about you're like
every morning what am i clear about or
yeah you know how do you
apply that habit to your life uh i apply
in a couple ways
first for me uh every situation i go
into
i'm consistently asking like what what's
the feeling i want to
have here if you ever see me teach it's
often i would say bring the joy
so i have joy triggers that i've set up
in my mind that makes me more
intentional
about things so for example a door frame
trigger whenever i walk through a door
i say bring the joy so when i walk
through that door right there it's like
bring the joy into this room it's just
it's just a mental trigger that i've set
up for myself
every morning in the shower i ask myself
three questions
and not that i shower every morning
the first question i say what can i be
excited about today
so it forces me to be clear about what's
going to draw
joy enthusiasm for me number two i say
what might trip me up today
because usually i know what's going on
today i'm like what what might mess me
up what my
where might i perform well what might
bother me and number three i say what
can i do
to surprise somebody today to give a
gift of appreciation
or acknowledgement today and so i think
through that in the morning so i think
that helps me begin my day pretty clear
then when i sit down before i do work i
literally look at my calendar of the day
this morning and i look at whatever's
going on the day and i think about it
for 20 minutes
it's one of my 20-minute routines in the
morning i literally
think about my calendar for 20 minutes a
day
people think that's crazy but what i'm
thinking through when i'm looking to
count i'm like okay i'm gonna have that
call
what do i want to happen on that call
you know what's my intention for that
call what's my goal for that call what's
the feeling for that call how do i want
to end that call
you know i'm gonna have that time with
louis like how do i
want to be there and and how can i make
sure i enjoy it because it's a big deal
you know i love your show i want to do a
good job i want to
share something good for the people even
though i have no idea what you're going
to ask right
i want to be present for that and and
make sure i i'm
i'm really there even though maybe i
have a head cold today you know it's
like
it's like just thinking through it i
think that helps me
it keeps me asking questions every
sunday i do a life arenas assessment
that just means i think there's 10 areas
of our life and i score myself in them
and this is about my 11th year of doing
this wow so each area of my life
you know from from emotional quality to
happiness to relationships to time to
hobby
et cetera i just give myself a score of
one to ten
and one means i suck and i was horrible
in the previous week on that
10 means i did a good job and then i
asked how can i do better
it's my sunday routine yeah and it just
keeps me clear
and it's not like i don't sometimes like
everyone else
you know wonder what's going on or what
i'm doing but
those habits those were my habits you
have to establish your own for seeking
clarity but when you have them
you weaponize your life i also knew that
like
of course i'd have to work really really
hard if i was ever gonna make it
of course i'd have to get back up every
time i got knocked down
on the journey but i knew if i was gonna
make it like the most important thing
came down to me believing that i could
and for me you know and here's the thing
a lot of times we hold ourselves back
because we say things to ourselves like
oh i'm not qualified or
oh i feel this like dream on my heart to
whatever it is launch a podcast whatever
it is
but it's like oh but i'm you know don't
know how and i don't know i have no
connections and all the things we tell
ourselves and
for me in a way it almost made no sense
that i created a beauty company right
and
just the idea of it because i didn't
know anything about it i knew no one in
the industry
but every time i get still like for me
um and you know no matter what people
believe whether it's they're hearing the
universe talk to them or god talk to
them
like for me i hear it through my own
intuition
negotiation secret number one and that
is start with
no start with no instead of going into a
scenario going to negotiation that
oh i got to close this deal i have to
get this deal
the minute you are not attached the
minute you start with no
it's almost like i expect this is gonna
go well but at the same time i'm not
attached i call that walkaway power the
minute you say you know what
it would be nice if we do this deal but
i'm perfectly okay
if we don't do the deal so the minute
you are okay to walk away from the deal
then your the the other party the person
that you are negotiating with
can feel that hey you're not needy
you're not desperate you're here
to work out a win-win deal and that's
that's very very good
so start with the no in your mind
first so you're not attached so that's
secret number one
secret number two and that is always
find the hidden motive in other words
what motivates this person what
motivates
this party not what they say not what
they say hey this is what i want i want
these things but
deeper what's the motive behind it
right what's the motive behind the
motive they might say they want
this they want that but what is it is it
they might say oh
i want this price anything less than
that i'm not going to say yes to
well is it price or is it something
else could it be that if they don't do
this deal this there's
some kind of deadline there's there's
urgency that you may not be aware of
so if you take a little bit of time and
do your research
or you ask if you're not good questions
or
you just find out maybe from the people
around them
what motivates this person what are the
hot buttons
once you find that when you're going in
and you are not attached
but at the same time you've done your
homework negotiation
very often is about doing your homework
right whoever
does the most amount of homework about
the other person
you will have an inch that's secret
number two secret number three
and that is ask for the moon
ask for the moon so imagine you are
negotiating
about a particular deal
so when you just ask and say hey i want
this
well no i'm not going to give you that
well i want this
well i'm not going to give you that now
you are fighting over
this one thing right it either becomes a
yes
or no kind of scenario instead
when you are asking something ask for
the mood
meaning this let's say there are ten
things listen let's say there are three
things that you want out of this
scenario
right out of this negotiation don't ask
for three
ask for five or ten so when you're
negotiating you say okay i want
one two three four five six seven eight
i want these ten things the other party
would be like what they would
freak they're like no that's that's
crazy i'm not gonna give you
like these 10 things you're insane
there's no way there's no deal to be
made here
right and you're like well
so what could you do well i'm not going
to give you 10 things
you know the most i could give you is
like four things or five things or three
things
good because those are actually the
three things that you
want in the beginning so when you ask
for the moon you give them a little bit
of leeway
to negotiate to kind of hackle right to
knowing hey you're not going to get it
all but if you can have it you get one
third of it you're happy and that's
what you want in the beginning anyway
that's the outcome that you want
right so ask for the moon but when you
do it you gotta you gotta practice
right you gotta practice almost with a a
strict face
right you gotta practice with
negotiating it's very very professional
why things are the way they are right
now with
uh political correctness social norms
which i think is a
disaster outright disaster i hate it um
and i'm not quite sure what to make of
it in terms of where is it going but
i'd like to know what your take is on
like how all this insanity started
wearing it's about feelings and hurting
political correctness in my judgment is
a manifestation of lack of self-esteem
when i uh uh grew up i had an alpha male
dad
superhero from the second world war in
the korean war who looked like
i mean he had a 56 inch chest a 30 inch
waist and he had 18 inch arms and he'd
never lifted weights
okay and i thought and all his buddies
if you will
from the second world war in the korean
war look more or less like him
and they allegedly and in reality they
saved
the generation from all they called up
the greatest generation
right and so i thought everybody was
like that
um and when i went out into business and
i made a lot of money and then
when i got thrown out of the company i
found it the what was i going to do and
i thought well i'll go back and teach
university it's a long-winded answer to
your question
and i taught university for one dollar
an honors class and i was
really dismayed and so then i said well
i'll coach the the meatheads the kids
and because i thought everybody had some
sort of self-esteem
now uh when i was at bear stearns almost
everybody
had self-esteem at some level okay and
do you in new york at the time
ambassadors
yeah what years was that yeah it was uh
70
uh seven through uh eighty one two ace
greenberg
oh aj's hired me cy lewis hired me cy
lewis himself
and uh and i was the most successful not
allegedly non-jew in the parliament
and they always said that i was
sephardic you know and they said you've
got to be
jewish it's all right don't be ashamed
don't be ashamed
uh uh and so um but they were pushy guys
i mean and we weren't the white shoe
guys you know like the goldman sachs or
those
those kind of guys we were pushing guys
it got done and so but
there i was still surrounded with guys
that had a lot of self-confidence
and a lot of self-esteem uh and so i was
uh led to believe
that um self-esteem wasn't such a rare
commodity or quantity whatever you want
to call it but in reality we
both know it is yeah and self-confidence
self-esteem etc uh
and so the um the world today is
um political correctness back to your
original question
is because we want people to like us we
want to fit in
uh we we don't want to stand out
in a day when somebody will commit
suicide on facebook because they're
disliked it's beyond my comprehension i
can't understand it i just don't
and why the parent of the kid that kills
himself doesn't go kill
his parents is beyond me you know
there's certain things
uh worth dying for and that's one of
them in my judgment
and it's so it's but it's getting worse
and worse and worse we've all been told
that money
doesn't grow on trees and what that is
is
we feel that money is scarce or in fact
we live in a fear that it's going to run
out or going to vanish
and and we know that money doesn't
vanish money is not
going away there's the same amount of
money if not more
around the world than there's ever been
it's not getting smaller
think about that like really think what
i just said money is not shrinking
right in fact this year in america alone
and i've said the stats a lot of you
have heard this but
because it boggles my mind that there's
1700
new millionaires being created every day
in america
think about that 1700 new millionaires
every single day in america
is that 80 doing the math yeah like
every hour every every
i mean it's crazy right so think about
that and and
i took some notes here so instead of
instead of the question
and this is this is one i really want
you to think about
what happens is when we think about
money is scarce and it doesn't go on
trees and we have this
feeling that it's getting shrinking and
it's going away what we ask ourselves is
this
how do i protect myself how do i save
this money how do i make sure
no one takes what i have
and that mindset keeps you on the
sidelines
i want you to say what about asking
yourself a different question because
here's the thing if money
doesn't disappear if we know it's the
same amount or more can we agree on that
if it's not disappearing then all it is
is money is moving from one group of
people
to another group of people same amount
of money if they're still
let's say there's a hundred dollars and
you're moving it around amongst a bunch
of people it's just
who's getting the chunk of it there's
still a hundred dollars the same sum
total is there it's just moving
differently
so the question you should be asking
yourself is now how do i hold on
to what i have how do i make sure i
don't lose any of this how do i make
sure you know
i keep the lights off at night i'm not
saying you shouldn't be conservative
what i'm saying is instead of having
that mindset what we should be saying is
how do i become the person and this is
one write this down i hope you i hope
you're paying attention here today guys
i hope you're not playing with social
media looking around trying to focus on
this
because the question should be how do i
become
the person where the money is moving to
rather than away from right just the
same little
same thought process just a different
shift instead of instead of thinking
money is scarce and it's going away even
though there's 1700 new millionaires a
day in america alone being created
right now money's not getting scarce
it's just those people money is flowing
to them
and somebody else who's standing there
trying to protect the little protect
themselves
and and being thinking a scarce mindset
their money is slowly
going away now i am surely not going to
be an
advocate or say that you shouldn't be
conservative that you shouldn't save
money that you shouldn't be smart with
your money
of course you should but here's what i
know
in the evolution of my life of going for
that kid living in a bathroom with my
dad
and not having money and all those
things and i'm not saying that to give
you my
my my my pitch or my story but
when i look back at when i tried to save
and be conservative because i listened
to
you know maybe grandparents that went
through the depression or listen to
people that you know is like you're
crazy
what i realize is when you change your
mindset on money
when you gain the capabilities and when
you take action
it is in my opinion you could disagree
with me in my opinion money is easier to
flow to you
and make it than it is to save it i even
look at that in my business i'm like hey
let's tighten up on expenses and i'll
look through all these things like okay
if we tighten up all those because we're
such a big company now
we could save this much but if we if i
write a new book if i start a new
campaign if i do some more real estate
deals i can bring in this much with a
little with the same amount of effort
like save this much or just make this
much how to hold it keep everybody there
keep the lights on i'm gonna go make it
over here now
i might be an extreme but i'd like to
give you a little bit of that
that if we stand on the sidelines
envying those making more
being not jealous but like desiring what
other people have but we're afraid
because we want to hold on to what we
have and be afraid to take action if you
had to sum up
the your message about life what would
you
say i mean you know
my name is dame dash right and uh
what does the dash in between the
beginning of when you
born you die that dash that's the life
that's your life so
i think we're here to live we're here to
learn
you know we're not here to be perfect
we're supposed to embrace all our
imperfections
and i think if we find and can imagine
the bright side
in anything that will become a reality
but you can't think anything's going to
be given to you other than opportunity
and the only way to show appreciation
for opportunity is to react
not to say thank you but to actually do
something
and not everyone gets opportunities so i
think
appreciating those opportunities is
really important because
the next time those opportunities will
not be presented and i think
every single day for everybody there's a
lesson
there's a test and if you don't pass the
test you do not move forward
you stay in the same place and then that
test becomes a little harder and if you
don't pass it again
you actually go backwards and then
instead of the test being in front of
you
where you could look at the test and sit
back at you and it's smacking the [ __ ]
out of you in the back of your head
and it hurts and it's embarrassing so i
always advise people to look out for
those tests
not the ones when people are looking
just when no one's looking i'm going to
share something with you that could
change the course of your life
could make everything so much better to
do this to explain it properly i'm going
to tell you a little story
he goes way back 57 years
a man gave me this book he said bob do
exactly what i tell you
and you can have anything you want now
when he said that i was flat broke
i had six thousand dollars in debt and i
was only earning four thousand dollars a
year
the prospects of thing getting better
were pretty slim
i had two months high school formal
education i had absolutely no business
experience
i was not in a good spot but he said
listen there are reasons why you can't
win bob
he said if you do what i tell you and
study this book
is you're going to figure out how you
can now this is napoleon hill's book
think and grow rich he spent his whole
life studying 500 of the world's most
successful individuals and he found
there was a golden thread running
through their life and that's what's in
this book
i've never stopped reading it i then
found a condensed narration of the book
by earl nightingale where earl took and
he condensed the whole thing
and he put it on a long playing record
and i would listen to that and listen to
it and listen to it
in fact i had started my own company and
i used to play the records to the sales
people every morning
well one morning it was very early just
finished the salesman and just finished
playing earl's record
and i said at the end of the meeting i
said man i'd really love to meet him
one of the sales people said no you
wouldn't he said what do you mean i
wouldn't
he said if you really wanted to meet him
you'd go and meet him and it's that
intercepted you're right
i got on the phone and i got an
appointment with earl nightingale
now that wasn't an easy thing to do earl
was the most listened to men in the
history of the broadcasting industry at
the time
earl nightingale lloyd conan started the
night galcona corporation who literally
started the personal development
business as we know it today
in recorded fashion he was considered
the dean of personal motivation
there was probably a couple of million
people that would have loved to sat down
with him
but i got the appointment at the end of
the meeting i had a wonderful time there
when i was leaving i said earl what is
the big deal
what is the real secret of light to
making things happen
well he said there isn't any secret to
success bob he said it's a
simple matter of figuring out what you
absolutely love to do
and then make a decision to dedicate
your life to it
then every day you're going to be doing
what you love to do so the problem with
most people is they
never decide what they love to do and
they don't make a decision to dedicate
their life to anything they just go from
one thing to the next
i read an incredible study that changed
the way i
create and think and it said that the
human mind can't be logical and creative
at the same time
how many of you have ever walked from a
highly creative brainstorm where you
were
fueled with passion and then had to talk
about numbers and business and
right it's tough right anyone ever found
that quite difficult it's quite
challenging and the mind's like
trying to run from one side of the brain
to the other side of the brain so what i
do is i
create in depth so i go really deep into
my creation and then
i go really deep into everything else
that i have to do so before i went to
india
i created my content in advance and so
when i was in india i was able to really
switch off
so the beauty of being able to be in
india for 21 or 30 days or wherever i am
in the world for that matter
and then not having to think of
creativity as stress or pressure i'm
able to
do creativity as a form of passion and
service and so when i was in india i was
able to not look at instagram
i was able to not look at facebook i was
able to completely switch off for 21
days when i was there earlier in january
and i started my year in the way i
wanted to so i was meditating for eight
hours a day i was spending time with my
teachers who are
mind-blowing and incredible and trying
to learn from them and taking knowledge
and wisdom from them
and continuously praying to be of more
service this year and make a difference
this year so
that's how i chose to spend my january
and i had so many people saying to me
they were just like
jay it's january things are going well
in your career
how can you take 21 days off right that
pressure that noise
of like things are going good for you
how can you take time off i was like
things are going good because i'm doing
this
all right like you know i had one of my
teachers that has kept saying to me for
years he goes if you want to move three
steps forward you have to go three steps
deep
and so if i'm not going forward i know
it's because i haven't gone deep
so for me that's a big priority for me
and that's what i try and do when i'm
i try and do that every day but i also
believe in immersive experiences
so a lot of us today we live in this
world which is like 10 minutes a day do
it for 10 minutes today everything will
be great and that is great there's
nothing wrong with that
but imagine you spent with a boy or a
girl your partner whoever it was someone
that you just started dating
imagine you spent 10 minutes a day with
them how long would it take you to
figure out whether you wanted to fall in
love with them or not
probably a long time and so when you go
immersive if you spend a weekend away
with someone you know whether you like
them or not
and meditation mindfulness all these
habits are the same the more you immerse
yourself
the more you get an experience that
stays with you the more that you can
live with that experience and
keep going back to it for 10 minutes a
day so i really believe in immersive
experiences
i love the 10 minute a day advice but i
also deeply believe in having an
deep immersive absorbed
experience that completely
takes over your whole body mind and soul
so the most powerful decision we make
most of us don't make it consciously is
what are we going to focus on
we don't focus on everything we focus on
a small number of things and that's what
we experience in life
because you could be focusing right now
on the blood rushing through your left
ear or the touch of your clothes against
your skin but you don't
most of what your brain does is distort
delete and generalize
it makes life simple and the problem is
you distort delete and generalize you
miss a lot of your life
and focus right down equals feeling
whatever you focus on you're going to
feel even if it's not true
if i asked you there are two things you
could focus on what you have
or what's missing which one do you spend
more time focusing on
if your brain is constantly focusing
what's missing how can you ever sustain
happiness no matter how successful you
become
it is impossible what happens when you
focus on what you have
you feel alive you feel no scarcity you
feel joy how many of you have lots of
things in your life that if you focused
on it you could feel grateful for you
could feel excited about
how many got lots of things like this
now say i
but it doesn't exist unless you focus on
it and we all have patterns of focus
do you tend to focus more on what you
can control but what you can't control
what's outside your control
what is someone gonna feel is constantly
focused on what's missing and what they
can't control
sad frustrated angry depressed
so why are they still depressed because
they're still focusing on what's missing
and they're focused on what they can't
control and i'll add one more
do you tend to focus more on things from
the past the present or the future we
all do all three but if you're going to
spend your predominant time and you want
enjoyment it's the present if you want
to be create a great life it's the
future so it's a balance between the
present and future
and then in the company um i don't know
if i've ever told you this story
but uh one day i was in new york and i
was
having like a really bad pms craving for
carbs i was just like
i was like mama needs some carbs and i
was feeling like a croissant and there
was this
great little french bakery around the
corner that i've never been to and i'm
like i'm gonna go get my croissant right
now
so i roll up to this little french
bakery and on
the window there was like this handmade
sign that said you know
offer vacation back you know july 18th
and it was like this two-week thing
wow you're like what and i was like wait
wait what your business you need to be
here
yes and yet there it was empty and this
simple little like hand-drawn sign
and in that moment lewis i had this
notion i was like wait a minute i'm
running this digital company i have
all of these amazing beautiful gorgeous
souls that i work with
and we're producing content once a week
every week
non-stop when do we ever take a break
and the
advantage for me like josh who works in
entertainment like
siri sometimes they'll have you know you
watch your favorite series like i love
hands handsmaid's tale i love
stranger things you see 11 or 12
episodes
and wait a year and yes and then they're
off for a little while
right and i thought to myself why do i
not have down time built into my
business and this was about the time
when also
there was just a cultural uprising with
like you know hustle 24 7 and you have
to work non-stop and like
never take a break and i'll i'll sleep
when i'm dead and i'm like those are
horrible messages for your health yeah
so we decided after i saw so after i had
my
croissant craving i told my uh director
of operations i said
starting right now we're gonna close the
company down for two weeks in the summer
and two weeks in the winter and in
addition to people's
already having their yes their vacation
time
and we started that i guess maybe i
don't know five six years ago
i might be wrong on those dates but a
good number of times ago
and so our company goes dark twice a
year
and now the company's at a place where
not everyone in customer service takes
off those exact same two weeks so they
stagger
so that we can take care of people but
everyone has two weeks of dark time
two weeks of dark time and what's great
about that is that you don't get
fomo thinking that you're off and
there's all these other things happening
and there's projects moving ahead and
there's these things that you want to be
in on but you're like
feeling that tension because the rest of
the company is moving ahead and you're
trying to relax so it's been a game
changer for us
wow as a team the hardest way to create
wealth
it's also the most rewarding way to
create wealth but the hardest way to
create wealth is to be an entrepreneur
because if you follow the flow of the
income statement and you see who gets
paid first if you just go through
the income first the suppliers then you
pay your staff
then you pay the government taxes then
you pay the bank interest
then you pay yourself dividends so the
entrepreneur in the business gets paid
last
but unless we go through an education
system that teaches us these things
what happens is we breed entrepreneurs
you're seeing it now who think
entrepreneurship is
instant money do you see whereas
any person who's a real entrepreneur and
i'm not with respect i'm not talking
about people who pose as entrepreneurs
i'm talking
real entrepreneurs will tell you that it
takes a long time and it's very hard
so that's why you need an education
for people who want to be an
entrepreneur and it doesn't have to be
commercial education
you can go study architecture it doesn't
matter as long as you've studied
the discipline repetition like study the
thing
i discovered at an early age i didn't
think i was much good at anything
and uh but my father did bit me a big
favor he had me
working in all my spare time from the
time i was six
because he he announced he didn't want
his sons to
be country club moms he wanted us to
feel
grateful for everything and entitled to
nothing
and and for whatever reason when you say
working he didn't give you some cushy
office job in the company no no no not
particularly at age six i started out
digging dandelions and when i say dig
dandelions you don't pull them out
you dig them down and you have to get
the entire route or they'll come
right back and i remember there was a
club and a swimming pool across the
street from us and i'm out there in 105
degree heat digging these and i could
hear
my friends my little six-year-old
friends
they're swimming and jumping off the
diving board and i could recognize
each one squeal was different of joy
and i'm thinking why does my father
hate me and their fathers love them i
found out that if you don't and then
then i of course graduated to shoveling
out stalls
and milking cows and that doesn't sound
like
much work but oh it it's it's hard work
so i would milk cows before school and
then again after school
martin milk milk or cows and digging
post holes and all these things
but i discovered that much later
that if if you don't learn to do dirty
jobs if you don't learn
unpleasant work you by the time you're
in your 30s you never learn to work
productively and so he was doing me a
huge favor
so it was beyond the work ethic
it taught you how to work productively
and how to work with others
in mutual benefit for example if a group
of you during a dirty job
you don't try to stick it to them make
them do more then they'll try to do it
to you
and the work goes on and on you want to
work together
to get it done as efficiently as
possible you want to understand who your
customer
is how do what does my customer want
what does he value i better do this the
right way or i'll have to do it again
i'm going to tell you right now either
you're going to control your time
or your time is going to control you
either you are going to dictate the
terms of your life or you're going to be
somebody who reacts and responds
throughout their life this device right
here can both speed up time in your life
or it can slow it down it's not always a
speed tool
so one of the tips that i've covered
before but not enough people
implement that i promise you is a
quality of
out performance that relates to their
time is they control it they do not
react and respond
they dictate the terms of their life
most of the time
and that means this when you wake up in
the morning the greatest thing you could
do for yourself
is not touch or look at this device for
30 minutes to an hour after awakening
so that when you wake up you take
control of your time
you control the time you control the
beginning of the day
you get clear you meditate you pray you
stretch
you think you go through a gratitude
exercise you
control the first 30 minutes of your day
it sets a tone that i'm in charge of my
time
not what enters this if the first thing
you do is grab this this now dictates
the term
of your day this controls my day what
hits this what email what text
what call hits this what instagram post
hit this
this controls me it controls my time but
if you can stay away from it for the
first 30 minutes to an hour
you send a message to your brain to
yourself that you
control time that this day is on your
terms and again
you stack up a day a week a month
a year five years of a lifetime
of you controlling and dictating the
terms of your life for just the
first 30 minutes to an hour every day it
will revolutionize your life
all i'm ever doing is trying to take
empathy gratitude kindness
positivity optimism and create
repackaging for it in modern society
to help somebody see it because life is
one big game of perspective
and if you've been raised by parents in
an environment and have natural dna
that makes you look at something upside
down i've gotta flip it
and when i say i got to i have this
enormous
love and need for admiration that i've
come to realize
admiration will not come in the form of
me making the most money
admiration will not come in any other
form than if i give so much more to you
than i expect from you in return i was
gifted
an ability of the gift to gab i am
creative
i understand attention graphs i have
work ethic i have aspirations
all of that has created one big game
where i feel responsibility
to be able to get this message out in a
way that won't get to people
that can never become monks or that
won't become
disproportionately high educated
philosophical
i'm in the trenches with my style but
it's the same
product and so 400 trillion to one was
one way for me to get people to be like
do you
understand
there's nothing any of us in this room
will accomplish that is even in the
galaxy of that we have a chance to do
something
yeah i just don't understand what are
you going to complain about today
that is even remotely close to never
having the ability to have a life
like what what are you going to complain
about like what's so in your life
like you've got the at-bat
even if you're the worst ranked person
7.7
billion in the world you're born to
slavery and genocide in a fifth world
country
where you're raped every day starved
slaved
lose your parents no love the game of
life
actually still creates the rare
potential
for you to break out of that and go on
to do something
and then bring positivity to the world
better than not being born at all
you know my husband and i married for 34
years
and we have two daughters and every day
you have to make a decision on whether
you are going to be a wife or a mother
in fact many times during the day you
have to make those decisions
and you have to co-opt a lot of people
to help you
we co-opted our families to help us we
plan our lives
meticulously so we can be decent parents
but if you ask our daughters
i'm not sure they will say that i've
been a good mom i'm not sure
and i try all kinds of coping mechanisms
i mean i'll tell you a story that
happened when
my daughter went to catholic school
convent of sacred heart and every
wednesday morning
they have class coffee with mothers
class coffee with mothers for a working
woman how is it gonna work
how am i gonna take off nine o'clock on
wednesday mornings to go for a class
coffee
so i miss most class coffees my daughter
would come home and she'll say
list of all the mothers that were there
and you were not their mom
first few times i would die with guilt
but i
developed coping mechanisms i called the
school and i said give me a list of
mothers who are not there
so when she came home when she came home
in the evening
she'd say you were not there you were
not there i said aha mrs rag wasn't
there you know mr so-and-so wasn't there
so i'm not the only bad mother you know
you have to cope because
you die with guilt you just die with
guilt
my my observation david is that the
biological clock
and the career clock are in total
conflict with each other
total complete conflict when you have to
have kids
you have to build your career just as
you're rising to middle management your
kids need you because they're teenagers
they need you for the teenage years
and that's the time your husband becomes
a teenager too so he's easier
i'm sorry
they need you too so what do you do and
as you grow even more
your parents need you because they're
aging
so we'd be screwed i mean we have no we
have no
we cannot have it all but you know what
coping magazine mechanisms
train people at work train your family
to be your extended
family you know when i when i'm in
pepsico i travel a lot and
when my kids were tiny especially my
second one we had strict rules on
playing nintendo
she'd call the office she didn't care
whether i was in china or japan or
india wherever she'd call the office the
receptions pick up the phone
can i speak to my mommy everybody knows
if somebody says can i speak to mommy
it's my daughter
so she said yes tara what can i do for
you i want to play nintendo
and the receptionist has a set of
questions have you finished your
homework
you know you see
i say this because that's what it takes
she goes to the questions and she says
okay you can pay nintendo half an hour
but she leaves me a message tara called
at five
this is what the sequence of questions i
went through i've given her permission
so it's seamless parenting
but if you don't do that i'm serious if
you don't develop
mechanisms with your secretaries with
the extended office
with everybody around you it cannot work
if you want seven more habits that
billionaires do daily check the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there i'm not
smarter than anybody else but i can
outwork you by far the best investment
you can make is in yourself
it's never work when you're pursuing
your ambition
it's just it's just who you are